[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando mi hija era pequeña nos gustaba
ir a comprar el pan a una diminuta
panadería de mi pueblo
además de buen pan y buena conversación
tenían dulces y golosinas así que no era
raro que saliésemos por la puerta con
algunas chuches
una de las visitas que más recuerdo
coincidió con el cumpleaños de mi hija
que entró corriendo a decirle a la
panadera que ya era mayor que tenía seis
años
al oírla la panadera salió del mostrador
y preparó una brocheta con seis nubes de
azúcar de diferentes formas y colores y
mientras lo hacía le explicaba a mi hija
que será un día muy especial y que había
que celebrarlo
así que le deseo feliz cumpleaños y le
regalo la brocheta de nubes de azúcar
mi hija se quedó impresionada y sólo
pudo decir gracias pero unos minutos
después de vuelta a casa me pregunto ahí
está
nosotros somos especiales
estábamos en el año 2010 y comenzaba a
hablarse del apocalipsis del comercio la
reconversión del comercio local que
muchos relacionan con la digitalización
y con el crecimiento del comercio
electrónico
quizás en aquel momento era exagerado
hablar de apocalipsis pero tras el
impacto del cob y ahora sí que empezamos
a temer que la catástrofe sea real para
el pequeño comercio no hay más que
pasear por las calles de nuestras
ciudades para ver la otra epidemia la de
las persianas cerradas
por eso creo que estamos en un momento
crítico
un momento en el que el comercio local
tiene que decidir si se resigna a
intentar sobrevivir en un futuro que
otros diseñan a sus espaldas o si elige
competir en un futuro que ellos mismos
van a ayudar a construir
este futuro dependerá de que cada gestor
de un comercio local y de un área
comercial urbana entiendan que esto ya
no va de comprar productos a un precio y
venderlos más caros esto va de aportar
algo valioso a la vida de las personas a
través de la experiencia de compra de
los productos el equivalente para cada
negocio a la brocheta de nubes de azúcar
esto no va a ser fácil porque requiere
un gran cambio y porque supone admitir
que lo que conocíamos ya no sirve y que
lo que ha funcionado hasta ahora será lo
que nos lleva al cierre
porque si podemos comprar cualquier cosa
desde nuestro teléfono móvil los
productos ya no son lo más importante de
una tienda
además las tiendas físicas ya no son el
primer lugar al que vamos a conocer un
producto oa informarnos así que
necesitamos un atractivo un valor
añadido para que los clientes vengan
ese valor añadido esa brocheta de nubes
de azúcar que va a hacer cada compra
inolvidable será distinta para cada
comercio
puede ser una atención excepcional como
la de mi panadero o puede ser una manera
distinta de comprar como la tienda de
alimentación en la que haces catas de
producto o en la que te enseñan a
cocinar lo que compras
las posibilidades son infinitas
el objetivo de la actualización del
comercio será que el máximo de comercios
de un área comercial urbana y el área
comercial en su conjunto ofrezcan
experiencias valiosas a sus clientes el
éxito de la actualización del comercio
local será que llenemos nuestras tiendas
de brochetas de nubes de azúcar
pero si no lo hacemos bien entonces sí
que podemos enfrentarnos al apocalipsis
del comercio que en su mayoría será el
apocalipsis del comercio local
pero antes de venirnos abajo conviene
recordar que el pequeño comercio siempre
ha tenido que enfrentarse a grandes
amenazas
desde el comercio de la capital hasta el
corte inglés' pasando por los centros
comerciales todos esos monstruos en su
momento iban a acabar con el pequeño
comercio y lo cierto es que cada uno de
ellos se llevó a una buena cantidad de
pequeños negocios por delante
pero muchos otros se actualizaron y
sobrevivieron y por cada negocio que se
cerró se abrió otro nuevo
el cambio los hizo más fuertes
pero como lo consiguieron
encontrando cada uno su brocheta de
nubes de azúcar la librería de patricia
sabiendo siempre que el libro necesitas
leer la peluquería de iñaki entendiendo
por dónde irá tu nueva imagen o la
pastelería de manu presentando te los
pasteles como si fuesen joyas
como decía la actualización no es una
tarea fácil pero el comercio local no
está solo
con mayor o menor acierto las
instituciones se están tratando de
ayudar a los comerciantes que tienen un
comercio y a los emprendedores que
quieren abrirlo
pero si quieren resultar útiles tienen
que cambiar tienen que ayudar a los
comerciantes a encontrar su brocheta de
nubes de azúcar
para encontrar eso que ya tienen
patricia iñaki y manu las instituciones
tienen que facilitar el trabajo de los
comerciantes en tres ámbitos personas
tecnología y condicionantes
por un lado debemos investigar
profundamente a las personas para saber
quiénes somos cómo vivimos y cómo nos
relacionamos
por ejemplo resulta curioso que adidas
decathlon o zalando sepan más de la vida
deportiva de una persona que el dueño de
la tienda de deportes que está al lado
de su casa
pues bien a partir de la investigación
el comercio debe decidir que puede
aportar su negocio a la vida de sus
vecinos
y esto implicará centrarse en algún
grupo de clientes porque no sé puede
resultar valioso para todo el mundo
por ejemplo será más fácil resultar
valioso para un ryanair desde una tienda
especializada en running que desde una
tienda de material deportivo en general
por otro lado la tecnología es
importante porque aumenta las formas de
conexión entre comerciantes y clientes
por ejemplo un buen ejemplo es la
adopción de muchos comerciantes de
what's up business y bici para poder
gestionar pedidos y pagos a distancia
durante el confinamiento pero también
hay muchos malos ejemplos en los que la
tecnología se convierte en un fin en sí
mismo y terminan decepcionando a
clientes y comerciantes
en cuanto a los condicionantes son
fundamentales porque marcan gran parte
de las expectativas que el comercio debe
cumplir
por ejemplo saber cómo y por qué
compramos conocer quiénes son nuestros
competidores y cómo cambian o tener
claro las oportunidades y las amenazas
que hay en nuestro entorno
el trabajo en estas tres áreas personas
tecnología y condicionantes será lo que
nos permita actualizar un negocio o
crear uno nuevo
esto supondrá revisar los productos y
las marcas que ofrece cada comercio sus
instalaciones la comunicación la marca o
el modelo de atención es mucho trabajo
que el comerciante no puede hacer solo
además es un trabajo que requiere un
conocimiento que el comerciante no tiene
porqué tener y que no tiene sentido que
adquiera
por eso las instituciones deben
facilitar que el comerciante pueda
trabajar de manera personalizada con
profesionales especializados en el
diseño de su experiencia de compra
valiosa de su brocheta de nubes de
azúcar
y los comerciantes por su parte deben
implicarse y deben esforzarse en poner
en marcha las acciones que salgan del
trabajo con los profesionales y el ciclo
no puede parar porque las necesidades y
las expectativas de los consumidores no
van a dejar de cambiar
y la competencia tampoco
pero si lo hacemos bien a cambio
tendremos un comercio local actualizado
más fuerte y atractivo que aumentará la
diversidad de la oferta y que mejorará
la calidad de vida de nuestras ciudades
un comercio local que podrá competir en
un futuro que habrá ayudado a cambiar
pero qué pasa con los consumidores los
consumidores no tenemos que hacer nada
los consumidores deberíamos ser
conscientes de que cada compra que
hacemos es una piedra que construye el
tipo de ciudad y el futuro que queremos
de manera directa e indirecta cada
compra hace posible que tengamos un
colegio cerca de nuestra casa que el
ambulatorio siga abierto
o que se mantenga limpio el parque en el
que juegan nuestros hijos
dicho así parece que estoy planteando
una obra social pero no es tan difícil
al final se trata de elegir esos
comercios que hacen nuestra vida un poco
mejor esos que nos hacen sentirnos
diferentes
la librería de patricia la peluquería de
iñaki la pastelería de manu
es tan fácil como salir a las calles de
nuestras ciudades a disfrutar de
nuestras brochetas de nubes de azúcar
[Aplausos]